I'm generally optimistic there are
things about which I am pessimistic
which are one that the political process
seems to be chronically myopic and there
are also concerns at least might in my
view about politicians who don't want to
tell straight stories to the American
people about the kind of issues that the
country or our society face on the other
hand when I look at medical research I
see enormous potential for dramatic
breakthroughs when I look at the
capability of American technology to
enable more people to benefit from
education I'm very optimistic whether
we'll use that technology in a proper
way remains to be seen I think it's Kate
it's possible to dramatically change the
American educational system I don't
think we're doing it at this point but I
think it's possible to do and there are
a number of examples of schools that
have made dramatic breakthroughs in
educating people from lower income
groups who did not have advantages that
perhaps some of us had I think there is
also the possibility of major
breakthrough his new energy area to
reduce our dependence on imported oil
and reduce greenhouse gases I see
scientists and engineers all the time
with great ideas whether we can actually
implement those quickly remains to be
seen but I remain optimistic so in
general I think that the march of time
and the march of humanity has been
positive in many respects but it's not
inevitable and without proper leadership
and without proper vision on the part of
the American society and its leaders
none of these things will happen it just
doesn't things don't run themselves you
need leadership you need
laterz you need bold thinkers you need
the people like Jonas Salk or Louis
Pasteur to lead the these revolutions
Norman Borlaug who is a great advance or
of the agricultural revolution save
hundreds of millions of lives there a
whole range of people like that who get
ideas and run with those ideas and
projeff to have a political system and
you have to have a society that is
willing to to nurture those and support
those people and it takes money it takes
the willingness of politicians to allow
innovation to occur it takes a society
that's willing to take risks with new
ideas that's that's critically important
hey